your mouth up to the screen
hey I'm Adam DeVine and I'm doing thirst
tweets with BuzzFeed uh this is the
second time I did this I've did this in
2019 with my boy Blake Anderson and
evidently they got some more spicy
they're sweets here we go
[Music]
first tweet number one his name is Adam
DeVine because his ass looks divine okay
I tweeted that one okay I'm doing my own
thirst tweets when will Adam DeVine kiss
me and nobody else
oh that lonely soul
I got you Adam DeVine is Daddy you can't
tell me otherwise I am looking like a
father aren't I I'm looking older by the
by the day you're like he it should be a
father
I get it Adam DeVine in a commercial yes
please come here baby let me eat you
mama loves you
all right you got a spoon girl gobble
gobble Adam DeVine could punch me in the
throat and I'd say thank you
you a freak what I want to make sex with
Adam DeVine and oh boy you should see
this guy's profile photo
he makes sex he doesn't have it he makes
it with potions
he's a sex wizard did anyone else notice
Adam DeVine has a fat ass [__] boy
you're not the only one
it's still shaking it's still shaking
there's something so enchanting about
the way Adam DeVine moves his body
I was hit by a cement truck as a boy uh
it hurts to walk is that enchanting to
you Adam DeVine could fit me into
Oblivion
yeah probably I'm really good at it
what I gotta do to marry Adam DeVine
I'll eat that ass I swear to God
yeah you figured it out you figured out
what you have to do to Mary Adam Vine my
wife's like Adam no ander's home Blake
Anderson Adam DeVine did you mean wet
dreams literally when we were creating
Workaholics that's what we the whole
time we're like God I just want to
create wet dreams in other news Adam
DeVine is so thick with two C's and I
had no idea I'm so glad like big fat
asses are in right now because there's
there's no losing it there's no believe
me I've tried there's no getting rid of
this thing I'm still counting the vast
number of sex stuff I would do to that
jackass Adam Divine
the vast number of sex stuff the vast
amount of sex apparatuses I would use to
employ on Adam Devine's fat ass Adam
DeVine could own my body I would leave
my entire life behind if Adam DeVine
wanted me specifically as he plays
Bumper in Pitch Perfect
oh buddy you have to talk to a therapist
me before watching that movie
me after watching that movie definitely
wants to [__] Adam Divine
which movie
that's the real question because some
wildly inappropriate and some still
doesn't make much sense hey just had the
most in-depth sex dream about Adam
DeVine dreams do come she went true
love the word play tonight I said that I
would let Adam DeVine murder my vagina
and I meant it there's a lot of like
murder
coinciding with uh people's genitals so
maybe we love
the nether regions and don't try to
murder it or is that a thing with the
youth now as as I said earlier I'm
getting getting older we My Generation
didn't want to murder each other's
vaginas or buttholes we wanted to enjoy
them like a tasty delicious treat why is
Adam DeVine so fine to me he could nut
me no questions asked
nothing no questions there
these kids they're so funny adults
consenting adults
that's what I meant by that that's what
I meant by that I would be in the middle
of an Eiffel Tower for Blake Anderson
and Adam DeVine thank you for saying
that that was a dream a pumpkin man mine
never came true but you know such is
life not all your dreams come true I let
Adam DeVine nut anywhere he wanted
sure
um the North Pole
I wanted not on the North Pole and see
if like polar bears come out huh and it
was today that I too realized I have a
wide hole
for Adam DeVine
stay gaping
hey I'm Adam DeVine that was my first
tweets for BuzzFeed and watched The
Outlaws only on
Netflix
[Music]
foreign